[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend zur
Zeit kann man ja den Eindruck haben dass
halb Deutschland krank ist es sind jede
Menge unterschiedliche Erkältungsviren
am Werk unter anderem die RS-Viren die
Kindern zusetzen und Grippeviren und
Corona mischt auch noch ein bisschen mit
das RKI schätzt das aktuell circa
neuneinhalb Millionen Menschen an
Atemwegserkrankungen leiden das sind
tatsächlich sehr viele mehr als man
sonst auf dem Höhepunkt schwerer
Grippewellen zählt Cornelia Strauß
berichtet
in München hat es heute geschneit es ist
kalt und nass ein Wetter bei dem sich
viele Menschen schneller erkälten als
sonst
Atemwegserkrankungen im Winter sind
nicht ungewöhnlich in diesen Wochen ist
deren Zahl aber außergewöhnlich hoch
meldet das Robert Koch-Institut fast 12%
der deutschen Bevölkerung leidet im
Moment daran das macht sich besonders in
den Arztpraxen bemerkbar wir haben
wirklich multiple infekt-patienten die
also mit Atemwegsinfektionen Schnupfen
Husten teilweise auch ein bisschen
Luftnot und zu uns kommen sehr teilweise
besorgt sind das ganze geht oft über
längere Zeit Tage Wochen also bis zu 10
Tage sind die teilweise schon krank und
ja kommen dann auch zum zweiten Mal und
so sind wir sehr sehr beschäftigt
Atemwegserkrankungen unterliegen einer
gewissen Saisonalität die Influenza im
Volksmund Grippe genannt kommt meist in
Wellen während der Pandemie sind diese
Wellen ausgeblieben zum einen weil die
Masken vor Ansteckung geschützt haben
zum anderen weil es insgesamt weniger
Kontakte zwischen den Menschen gab es
ist wahrscheinlich dass die
infektionszahl noch weiter steigt
insbesondere weil die Influenza
Impfquote niedrig und gleichzeitig die
mohnkompetenz ebenso niedrig ist weil
wir die letzten zwei Jahre kaum Kontakt
mit atemwegserregern hatten denkbar ist
auch dass wir deshalb steigende
Infektionszahlen in der Kliniken sehen
könnten es gibt immer eine gewissen
Verzug zwischen Infektionswelle und
Erkrankungswelle wegen
Atemwegserkrankungen sind in diesem Jahr
viele Beschäftigte nicht zur Arbeit
gegangen nach Angaben der Techniker
Krankenkasse doppelt so viele wie im
Jahr vor der Pandemie das beeinflusst
den Arbeitsalltag von vielen was seine
Arbeit und so merkt man schon dass auch
so Erkältungskrankheiten viel häufiger
sind so neben höhengeschichten und so
ich bin Sänger ich bin hier am
Gärtnerplatz Theater und da passiert
immer wieder was also wenn wenn Leute
keine Vorstellungen singen können aus
erkältungsgründen oder Grippe oder was
er immer dann waren da immer Absagen
vielleicht melden sich mehr Leute krank
weil man aufmerksam geworden ist dass
man einfach jetzt mit einer
Atemwegserkrankung auch wenn sie jetzt
nicht kompliziert ist einfach nicht mehr
zu Arbeit geht wenn der Hals kratzt oder
die Nase zugeht sind Apotheken auf die
ersten Anlaufstellen seit der Pandemie
und dem Krieg in der Ukraine sind viele
Arzneimittel schwer lieferbar das gilt
weniger für frei verkäufliche
erkältungsmedikamente die Nachfrage
danach ist im Moment riesig sie sehen
einfach deutlich dass mehr Menschen mit
Reizhusten
Schnupfen grippalen Infekten bei uns
durch die Türe reinkommen sehr viele
Kinder der sv-infekt ist ja auch in
aller Munde das sind alles schon
deutlich spürbare Zahlen wer sich vor
der Grippe schützen möchte sollte sich
jetzt dagegen impfen lassen das ist die
Empfehlung der Fachleute nicht nur für
ältere und chronisch kranke Menschen
die corona-pandemie hat ja vieles ans
Tageslicht gebracht unter anderem wurde
uns allen vor Augen geführt wie es um
die Digitalisierung hierzulande steht
nicht dass das eine neue Erkenntnis
gewesen wäre aber spätestens als es ums
Homeschooling ging wurde es dann auch
dem letzten klar oder der Antike
faxverkehr zwischen Gesundheitsbehörden
überhaupt Behörden viele Ukrainer die
nach Deutschland geflüchtet sind Staunen
nur wie wenig hierzulande online geht
und mit welchen Papierbergen Sie es zu
tun haben die neue Bundesregierung hatte
sich ja eine
digitalisierungsoffensive auf die Fahnen
geschrieben sehr viel passiert scheint
er aber bisher nicht zu sein das wurde
heute auch beim digitalgipfel in Berlin
deutlich Svetlana Ullmann und Romanesco
den Personalausweis gibt's hierzulande
weiter nur in Kartenformat eine Variante
nur für Smartphone Fehlanzeige an den
Schulen zeigte die Pandemie vor welchen
Herausforderungen der digitalunterricht
steht und wer hoffte ein Rezept beim
Arzt überall gleich aufs Handy zu
bekommen guckt ebenso in die Röhre
Finnland und Dänemark führen bei der
Digitalisierung Platz 13 nur für
Deutschland das reichste der 27
EU-Länder ist bei der Digitalisierung
nur Mittelmaß er will das ändern
verkehrs- und digitalminister Wissing
mit Hilfe eines Beirats der ein
dateninstitut bilden wird er unterstützt
die Ressource dabei schwerpunktvorhaben
umzusetzen schaut uns über die Schulter
konstruktiv gibt uns Hinweise wo wir
nicht schnell genug sind und schneller
werden können
Deutschland soll in die Top Ten doch es
reibt sich noch zu sehr im kleinen
Gerangel auf
wir haben eigentlich die Digitalisierung
nie wirklich zu Chefsache gemacht das
war vielen PolitikerInnen irgendwie die
wichtig aber dann doch nicht so wichtig
als dass man eine richtige Strategie mal
auf den Weg hätte bringen sollen und
dann haben wir natürlich noch den
Föderalismus das heißt verschiedene
Ebenen konkurrieren miteinander man
konkurriert er als dass man kooperiert
es gibt viele unterschiedliche Software
Lösungen lernen von den besseren
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz hatte die
estnische Premierministerin eingeladen
ihr Land rangiert immerhin auf Platz 9
des Rankings Kaya Callas gibt praktische
Tipps beispielsweise mit der Einführung
der elektronischen Identität
Scholz weiß um den Nachholbedarf nach
jahrzehntelangem schleifen lassen des
digitalen Ausbaus unter der Regierung
Kohl er lenkt den Blick auf Deutschlands
neuen Weg zu mehr technologischer
Unabhängigkeit
angekündigt sind und einigen weiteren
die noch kommen werden denke ich dass
wir der Standort für die
Halbleiterproduktion in Europa sein
könnten das wäre wirklich etwas das ein
Ökosystem schaffen würde damit nicht nur
Deutschland sondern auch die Europäische
Union nicht von anderen Regionen
abhängig sind
es gibt auch Verbesserungen im kleinen
Videokonferenzen sind seit der Pandemie
alltäglich geworden 72% nutzen Sie
Papier verbraucht durch Ausdrucken
gingen Firmen um 53% zurück und
Faxgeräte benutzen noch 40%. die
Ampelkoalition will zudem bis Ende 2025
unter anderem die Versorgung mit
Glasfaseranschlüssen für mindestens 50%
aller Haushalte in Unternehmen ausbauen
am Vorantreiben der Digitalisierung wird
auch die Regierung Scholz gemessen
werden
und zu dem Thema gibt es nachher im
heute journal Update noch ein
ausführliches Interview mit Markus
Beckedahl digital Experte und Gründer
von Netzpolitik ok jetzt Hans Wolf mit
den Nachrichten china will die
Wirtschaftsbeziehungen zu den arabischen
Golfstaaten verstärken Staatspräsident
pink kündigte am 3 und letzten Tag
seines Besuchs in Saudi-Arabien an
künftig mehr Öl und Gas aus der Region
zu importieren beide Seiten
unterzeichneten milliardenschwere
Verträge unter anderem zu Rohstoffen und
erneuerbaren Energien
Saudi-Arabiens Kronprinz bin Salman
sagte China sei ein wichtiger Partner
und die Zusammenarbeit habe positive
Effekte auf die gemeinsamen Interessen
es war hieß erst dritte Auslandsreise
seit Beginn der corona-pandemie
in Iran ist es nach der Hinrichtung
eines jungen Demonstranten zu wütenden
Protesten gekommen in Deutschland hat
das Auswärtige Amt den iranischen
Botschafter eingestellt
Bundespräsident steinmeier hatte heute
zu einer deutsch-iranischen
Gesprächsrunde ins Schloss Bellevue
eingeladen steinmeier sagte anschließend
er appelliere eindringlich an die
religiöse und politische Führung in
Teheran die Gewalt zu stoppen gegen
Kinder Frauen und Männer die auf den
Straßen und Plätzen Irans friedlich
demonstrieren
die russische Justiz geht weiter massiv
gegen Regimekritiker vor ein Moskauer
Gericht hat den oppositionellen zu
achteinhalb Jahren Haft in einem straf
Lager verurteilt weil er
Falschinformationen verbreitet habe in
einem Internet-Video hatte Yasin den
Krieg und vor allem den Mord an
Zivilisten im ukrainischen Botschaft
angeprangert den Urteilsspruch
kommentierte er mit demonstrativem
Gelächter
im Zusammenhang mit dem russischen
Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine ist von
einer Zeitenwende gesprochen worden so
von Bundeskanzler Scholz nun ist der
Begriff von einer Jury zum Wort des
Jahres 2022 gewählt worden gab die
Gesellschaft für deutsche Sprache in
Wiesbaden bekannt sie hebt mit der
jährlichen Aktion die Wörter hervor die
das politische wirtschaftliche und
gesellschaftliche Leben sprachlich in
besonderer Weise bestimmt haben
im spanischen Alicante sind die
europäischen Mittelmeeranrainerstaaten
mit der EU-Spitze zusammengekommen Thema
war unter anderem der geplante Bau einer
Gas- und wasserstoffpipeline von
Barcelona nach Marseille Spanien und
Frankreich wollen das Projekt gemeinsam
mit Portugal bis 2030 fertigstellen an
den geschätzten Kosten von etwa 2,5
Milliarden Euro soll sich auch die EU
beteiligen
wenn es in der EU wieder einmal Streit
gab mit Ungarns Regierungschef Viktor
Orban konnte er sich ja in der Regel
darauf verlassen dass Sie einige
Osteuropäer zumindest Polen und
Tschechien zur Seite springen doch das
hat sich durch den Krieg in der Ukraine
inzwischen geändert das Orban mit seinen
erpressungstaktiken sogar das Hilfspaket
für die Ukraine und neue Sanktionen
gegen Russland zu blockieren droht das
löst auch bei seinen Verbündeten blanke
Wut aus
doch nicht nur dass er sich in Europa
zunimmt isoliert ist für ihn riskant
auch zu Hause steht Orban unter Druck
und kann es sich eigentlich nicht
leisten auf europäische Gelder zu
verzichten Wolf Christian Ulrich
berichtet
entschuldigt euch rufen Sie und meinen
Orbans Regierung tausende Schüler Lehrer
und Eltern demonstrieren in Budapest für
bessere Bildung weil kein Geld da ist
sind tausende Lehrerstellen unbesetzt
und wer noch als Lehrer arbeitet kann
vom Lohn kaum leben
[Musik]
eine Schande dass unsere Bildung nicht
mit den anderen europäischen Ländern
mithalten kann
das Land den zwölf Jahren zerstört das
EU-Geld landete in Orbans Taschen wir
haben davon nichts bekommen
es brodelt seit Wochen im ganzen Land
hohe Preise geringe Gehälter und jetzt
wird das Benzin noch teuer lange
Schlangen vorgestern an den Tankstellen
die Regierung Orban musste ihren
benzinpreisdeckel stoppen denn die
Mineralölfirmen konnten zum Staatlich
vorgegebenen Preis nicht liefern und das
Benzin wurde knapp
sind die Ölgesellschaft des Ministerium
und einer Spitze Viktor Orban
was Ungarns Weihnachtsstimmung noch mehr
trübt 22% Inflation bei Lebensmitteln
gar 44% der Forint so schwach wie lange
nicht was importierte Waren teuer macht
Jahre werden sehr schlecht und diese
Frau schuld ist die EU
diese Meinung befeuert Orban seit
Monaten mit diesem Plakat nicht
Russlands Krieg sondern die EU
Sanktionen sein ein Bombenangriff auf
die ungarische Wirtschaft
das Resultat der Brüssel Sanktionen ist
das ungarische Familien jetzt nicht mehr
für 1,20 € tanken können so Orbans
Kabinett
ausgerechnet jetzt wird jedoch ein
eiskalter Wind durch Orbans Schatzkammer
weil Ungarn rechtsstaatliche Regeln
missachtet empfiehlt die EU-Kommission
rund 13 Milliarden Euro EU Geld ein
Ungarn einzufrieren ohne EU-Geld kann
eure bans Machtsystem nicht überleben
deshalb wird es für ihn brenzlig meinen
Experten
und das erklärt auch wieso
Premierminister Orban kein mittelscheut
eigentlich mit der Erpressung Zugang zu
diesen europäischen Geld zu bekommen
auch wann hat zum Beispiel noch immer
nicht über den Beitritt von Finnland und
Schweden zur NATO abstimmen lassen und
blockiert gemeinsame Ukraine Hilfe
ein großer Fehler wenn sich die EU von
ihm erpressen ließe sagt ein ungarischer
Oppositionspolitiker wer sich erpressen
lässt ist schwach wenn die EU das Geld
zahlt stellt sie sich selbst damit ein
schlechtes Zeugnis aus
Orban steht unter Druck von der EU der
Opposition und von Teilen seiner eigenen
Wähler eisiger Regen kam ihm zumindest
heute Abend zur Hilfe und vertrieb die
Demonstranten von der Straße
während die deutsche Fußballnation ihre
Wunden leckt dreht sich in Katar der
Ball weiter zum Publikumsliebling sind
dort die Marokkaner geworden sie spielen
inzwischen quasi für die ganze arabische
Welt und Afrika und werden insofern
nicht nur zu Hause in Marokko gefeiert
dort gibt es seit dem spektakulären 13:0
gegen Spanien eh kein Halten mehr das
bei der ersten Fußball-WM in einem
arabischen Land die Mannschaft einer
arabischsprachigen Nation so erfolgreich
ist prägt inzwischen das ganze Turnier
von regenbogenbinden ist denn Doha
längst keine Rede mehr nun rücken andere
politische Symbole ins Bild
Beobachtungen von Gulli
mit einem Sieg sind sie alle Marokkaner
geworden alle miteinander verbunden eine
arabische Nation die Geschichte
geschrieben hat in Dubai wie in Doha
Sudanesen Jordania Libanesen die hier in
Katar eine zweite Heimat gefunden haben
schreien befreit auch
die Sieger sind von unserem Blut sie
sind Araber deswegen unterstützen wir
Sie sie sind super wir sind alle
Marokkaner jetzt nicht nur Katara
ich bin so stolz das erste arabische
Land im Viertelfinale ich hoffe sie
gewinnen das Finale
selbst cutters Emir fühlt sich fortan
als Marokkaner
und Dubais Herrscher twittert nichts ist
unmöglich für die Marokkaner nichts ist
unmöglich für die Araber die Löwen und
die Menschen Marokkos wie stolz wir auf
euch sind
der Fernsehturm in Kairo erstrahlt in
marokkanischen Farben und die
Moderatorin eine bekannten Talkshow in
Ägypten sagt
als Araberin als Afrikanerin bin ich so
glücklich für Marokko vom Atlantik bis
zum Golf stehen die Araber hinter euch
selbst hier backt Irak in einem von
Krieg und krisengeschüttelten Land löst
Marokko Sieg eine Art dringend benötigte
Aufbruchstimmung aus und lässt plötzlich
alle innerarabischen Feindschaften
vergessen
wenn Marokko gewinnt gewinnt die
arabische Nation wir teilen Marokkos
Freude denn wir Araber sind ein Land
alle Hoffnungen ruhen auf ihm Marokkos
Trainer rekagi wir fühlen diese
positiven Schwingungen nicht nur ein
Land ein ganzer afrikanischer Kontinent
steht hinter uns und alle arabischen
Völker
jeder arabische Sieg ist auch Ihnen den
Palästinensern gewidmet ganz dura ist
voller palästinensischer Flaggen und
Symbole selbst marokko ist Nationalelf
lässt sich mit der Flagge abbilden auch
wenn viele arabische Staaten längst gute
Beziehungen mit Israel haben liegen die
Sympathie in ihrer Bürger woanders
Palästina ist unsere Gebetsrichtung wenn
jemand auch nur einen Tropfen arabischen
Blutes hat sollte er an Palästina denken
die palästinensische Sache ist unsere
Sache Palästina ist immer da in allen
arabischen Herzen
Palästina sei der Gewinner der Herzen
bei dieser WM davon sind viele arabische
Fans überzeugt
und dann schalten wir noch zur goldene
atai in Doha golini wenn man mal über
dieses Thema Flaggen sprechen und andere
Zeichen dass diese One Love Armbinden
auf dem Platz zu sehen sind das wurde ja
von der FIFA brachial unterbunden aber
gegen die Palästina Flagge hat man beim
internationalen Fußballbund nichts
einzuwenden
sicherlich ist diese Flagge ein
politisches Symbol und sicherlich
widerspricht die Flagge auch dem Mantra
der FIFA wo nach keine politischen
Symbole zugelassen sind nun hat die FIFA
bislang alle Medienanfragen dazu
unbeantwortet gelassen ich kann mir
vorstellen dass sie wenn sie diese
Flagge verbieten würde dass es dann zu
einem gewaltigen Aufruhr hier kommen
würde wahrscheinlich würde die FIFA
sagen nun ja Palästina ist seit 1998 ein
FIFA Mitglied samt seiner Flagge und
deswegen sehen wir die Flagge nicht als
politische Symbol an aber spätestens
hier kommt bei manchen Beobachter
vielleicht der Verdacht auf dass die
FIFA dann doch mit zweierlei Maß ist
wenn es um politische Symbole geht auf
jeden Fall kann man wohl sagen dass
diese WM sehr politisch ist und mit sehr
unterschiedlichen Perspektiven
ja ich habe oft den Eindruck dass es
hier zwei Paralleluniversen gibt die
manchmal aufeinanderprallen da gibt es
das Universum in dem es Menschenrechtler
gibt Menschenrechtsaktivisten gibt die
besonders laut sein wollen die
lgbt-rechte betonen wollen
Menschenrechte Frauenrechte und da gibt
es das Universum des Gastgeberlandes
Katar und seine arabischen Zuschauer und
da geht es immer wieder um die eigene
Kultur die eigenen Normen die eigene
Religion für die übrigens auch hier
Werbung gemacht wird da wird die WM auch
als Plattform benutzt und es geht um den
Respekt für all das dass gefühlt zu
wenig entgegengebracht worden sei das
wird ja oft betont vor diesem
Hintergrund
überrascht es dann auch nicht dass es
Berichte gibt wonach arabische Teams
hier vor hatten eine Armbinde zu tragen
die gegen Islamophobie gerichtet sei die
also gegen Feindschaft gegenüber
Muslimen gerichtet sei eine Idee die
muss endlich aber angeblich die FIFA
dann doch abgelehnt habe
danke ich dir
und wie gesagt morgen das Viertelfinale
Marokko gegen Portugal und wie die WM
heute weiterlief damit geht es jetzt bei
dir weiter Hans ja im ersten
Viertelfinale am Nachmittag ging es
zwischen Kroatien und Brasilien bis ins
Elfmeterschießen das Kroatien am Ende
für sich entschied Fabian wieseberg mit
dem Bericht
mehr als 105 Minuten beißt sich
Brasilien an den Kroaten die Zähne aus
dann Doppelpass Neymar noch ein
Doppelpass Neymar das scheinbar
erlösende 1 zu 0 für Brasilien
mit dem Rücken zur Wand spielt dann
endlich auch Kroatien nach vorne der
Schuss von Bruno Petkovic noch
abgefälscht eins zu eins
Elfmeterschießen der erste Brasilianer
dort Rodrigo und Dominik leverkowitsch
pariert schon im Achtelfinale war er der
kroatische Held der Elfmeterschießen der
insgesamt 7 Schütze im Islam auch sich
mit dem 4:2 für Kroatien damit muss
martinus treffen
Pfosten Brasilien ist raus und Kroatien
zum zweiten Mal nacheinander im
Halbfinale
und jetzt zur aktuellen Energiesituation
in Deutschland trotz der gut gefüllten
Erdgasspeicher hält die
Bundesnetzagentur ihren Appell zum Gas
sparen weiter aufrecht Sina meinet wir
sind die Einschätzungen zur
Versorgungssicherheit für den Winter die
Versorgungssicherheit die wird zwar nach
wie vor gewährleistet doch mit den
gerade sinkenden Temperaturen da draußen
steigt der Gasverbrauch drinnen der
Indikator zur lagebewertung wird bei
dieser Witterung von der
Bundesnetzagentur als kritisch
eingestuft und auch wenn die Gasspeicher
aktuell zu rund 96% gefüllt sind sinken
die Füllstände und es wird überlegt wie
einer gasmangelage vorgebeugt werden
kann wie von der Bundesnetzagentur
gefordert wäre dazu weiterhin eine
Einsparung von mindestens 20% nötig
außerdem sollten die Gasimporte nach
Deutschland stabil bleiben und die
lng-terminals für Flüssiggas müssten zu
Jahresbeginn einspeisen
das flüssiggasterminal in Wilhelmshaven
sollen noch vor Weihnachten in Betrieb
genommen werden bereits am 22 Dezember
könnte von hier aus dann erstmals Gas
ins deutsche Netz fließen jährlich
könnten dann mehrere Millionen Haushalte
hierzulande mit Erdgas versorgt werden
mit moderaten Kurs gewinnen am deutschen
Aktienmarkt wurden heute die Anleger
versorgt der DAX beendet den Handel mit
einem Dreiviertel Prozent plus und steht
zum Wochenschluss bei
14.371 Punkten ja vor den anstehenden
Notenbank Entscheidungen der
Europäischen Zentralbank einerseits und
der US-Notenbank fährt andererseits
waren die meisten Anleger hier heute
zurückhaltend oder vielleicht bei den
Temperaturen auch ein kleines bisschen
eingefroren
vielen Dank
die Vizepräsidentin des Europäischen
Parlamentes evakaeli ist noch
übereinstimmenden Medienberichten
festgenommen worden Hintergrund sind
offenbar Ermittlungen gegen mehrere
Personen wegen des Verdachts auf
Korruption im EU-Parlament es soll um
eine versuchte Einflussnahme durch eine
Golfstaat gehen in diesem Zusammenhang
gab es mehrere Durchsuchungen in Brüssel
fünf Personen wurden festgenommen
in einem wissenschaftlichen Gutachten
für die Kultusministerkonferenz drängen
Bildungsforscher darauf mehr für die
Kompetenzen von Grundschülern zu tun
ihre Empfehlungen Förderung soll schon
in der Kita beginnen in der Schule
sollen vor allem Deutschland Mathematik
verstärkt vermittelt werden mit dem
Durchschnitt sechs Stunden Deutsch und
fünf Stunden Mathe pro Woche es soll
regelmäßig geprüft werden ob die Kinder
Lernstandards erreichen und es soll mehr
Qualifizierungen für pädagogisches
Personal geben
für Bahnreisende verkürzt sich künftig
die Fahrzeit zwischen Stuttgart und
München um 15 Minuten nach 10 Jahren
Bauzeit ist heute im weiser von
baden-Württembergs Ministerpräsident
Kretschmann ein neues wichtiges Bahn
Teilstück eröffnet worden die 60 km
lange Neubaustrecke Wendlingen Ulm das
Bauprojekt war rund 4 Milliarden Euro
teuer
für uns im ZDF und besonders hier im
heute journal war das heute ein Tag mit
einer traurigen Nachricht
Ruprecht Eser der unsere Sendung lange
Jahre moderiert und auch die Redaktion
leitete es gestorben insgesamt war
Ruprecht 37 Jahre in unserem Sender in
vielen Funktionen ein echtes
zdf-urgestein wie wir hier gerne sagen
und ich glaube er würde sich freuen wenn
er wüsste dass es unser Kollege Christ
hat Läpple ist der jetzt dann ihn
erinnert
Journalismus war sein Leben zeigen was
ist sein Motto Ruprecht Isa in der
Lutherstadt Wittenberg geboren Flo seine
Familie vor dem Mauerbau aus der DDR in
den Westen als 1989 das
honecker-regimete war er Moderator beim
heute schon so konnte er den Wandel aus
erster Hand kommentieren mit einem
dieser typischen Esel Gedanken
der 77-Jährige Antifaschist Erich
Honecker hat die Bühne verlassen der
52-Jährige Egon Krenz hat sie betreten
noch am Montag hatten die mehr als
120.000 Demonstranten in Leipzig gerufen
Erich leitreformen ein oder gehen ins
Altersheim
Rupprecht ESAM studiert hatte er an der
FU in West Berlin fürs Leben gelernt bei
der BBC in London das waren meine
schönsten Jahre von 1967 bis 70 sagte
einmal Journalismus jenseits von
Schlagzeilen und Schlagworten das war
sein Ziel
im ZDF machte er raschkarriere 1978
beobachtete er das kanzlerpaar Helmut
und Loki Schmidt beim mitternächtlichen
passionsleben aus nächster Nähe wir
stehen Sie dazu wenn man sie Macher
nennt
das kann ich gut ertragen es kommt darin
offenbar auch ein gewisser Respekt zum
Ausdruck von dem sie eben schon
gesprochen haben übrigens Politiker
sollen nicht danach streben geliebt zu
werden
nah dran sein doch stets Abstand halten
ob in London oder in Mainz für Isa keine
leere Floskel es war sein Leben Anfang
der 90er Jahre versuchte er sich beim
Privatfernsehen er kehrte nach nur einem
Jahr zum ZDF zurück bis 2003 moderierte
er halb 12 eine Talkshow mit prominenten
Gästen doch sein persönlicher Glücksfall
blieb die Öffnung der Mauer als Mensch
und Moderator
der Kollege von DDR Fernsehen der darf
nicht mehr weiter drehen der kriegt den
zweiten Schluck
und ich weil ich so viel rede und weiter
reden muss Kriege ein ganz großen
fünften Schluck ein Doppelstock
offen für Neues sein das schätzte
Rupprecht Isa der ZDF-Journalist starb
in Hamburg im Alter von 79 Jahren
[Musik]
das was von uns gleich geht's mit der
heute-show weiter und um 0920 meldet
sich dann Hanna Zimmermann mit unserem
britischen Update und wir melden uns
morgen in der Halbzeitpause um 20:45 Uhr
da spielt England gegen Frankreich bis
dahin
[Musik]
guten Abend die Kälte aus dem Nordosten
hat Mitteleuropa und Westeuropa geflutet
da liegen morgen die Höchsttemperaturen
häufig im leichten Dauerfrost der Frost
ist das eine der Schnee das andere und
dazu schauen wir uns dieses Tief über
den Balearen genauer an das sieht
nämlich bis Sonntagabend über Italien
und Kroatien und Ungarn weiter nach
Polen bringt dort viel Schnee und auch
etwas Schnee in den Osten Deutschlands
gleichzeitig zieht hier ein Tief über
Spanien und Portugal weiter Richtung
Mittelmeer ein weiteres Tief gibt's hier
über der Nordsee und das bringt Schnee
z.B auch nach Großbritannien oder nach
Frankreich heute Nacht schneit es bei
uns jetzt z.B in Thüringer Wald oder im
Schwarzwald wenn es Auffahrt bildet sich
raschnebel Blatt kann es aber eigentlich
überall sein bei Tiefsttemperaturen
zwischen 0 und -5 Grad und direkt über
den Schneeflächen wird auch noch
deutlich kälter die Höchsttemperaturen
morgen pendeln meist um den Gefrierpunkt
und das Wetter dazu ist drei geteilt im
Nordosten ist es meist trüb etwas Sonne
kommt vielleicht zwischen dem Sauerland
und der Mosel zum Vorschein und von
Süden ziehen diese Schneewolken langsam
weiter nordwärts direkt am Alpenrand
können so innerhalb von 12 Stunden 10 cm
neue Schnee zusammenkommen sonst werden
es wohl nur wenige Zentimeter werden am
Sonntag zieht dieser Schnee weiter
Richtung Nordosten es kommt häufiger mal
die Sonne zum Zuge und in den nächsten
Tagen geht es sehr winterlich kalt
weiter ich wünsche Ihnen noch ein
schönes Wochenende